Jinny:
Girls, here is to marriages,
men,
parties.
Not particularly in that order.
- (laughs)
- Oh!
But darlings,
we always come first.
♪ upbeat pop music ♪
Mrs. Testvalley:
For certain girls of refinement,
New York has become too limited.
I quite agree.
I insist that I invite you
and your daughters to London.
London?
London, London?
Conchita:
For the debutante's ball.
(cheering)
♪ string music ♪
- (sipping)
- Mrs. Brightlingsea: Americans,
they're all new money.
And I'm quite sure
they'll be frightful.
Lord Brightlingsea:
We must just grit our teeth
and think of
the bucket loads of cash.
Jinny: Here is to a new world.
♪ dramatic music ♪
Patty: Shoulders back,
head high.
Be fearless.
Ooh!
- Sorry.
- I'm Nan.
- Welcome.
Fresh from New York.
Nan: Imagine a whirlwind romance
with a handsome English lord.
Conchita: Well, of course
you have no interest
at all in being admired.
I can admire myself, can't I?
♪ I pay attention to things
that most people ignore ♪
- They're like cattle.
- Rather harsh.
- I think they're all lovely.
- Nan: Yes, they are lovely.
But they're also human beings
who are funny and smart.
Theo: Girls I generally meet
don't think or talk so freely.
Or so passionately.
♪
Woman: Imagine not realizing
you're in the presence
of a duke. (laughs)
Oh, is this... Are you?
Jinny: What?
♪ I am light as a feather
I'm as stiff as a board ♪
Give me one good reason
why you couldn't be a duchess.
- I can't possibly.
- What actually is a duchess?
♪ "All-American Bitch"
by Olivia Rodrigo ♪
This is Guy Thwarte,
my oldest friend.
- You've met Nan.
- Guy: Yes.
- ♪
- ♪ Forgive and I forget ♪
Theo: She moves in such
an unexpected way.
♪ You can't resist ♪
- Have you noticed?
- Yeah.
♪ I'm a perfect
all-American bitch ♪
♪ With perfect all American ♪
Nan: Girls are taught that if
a story isn’t a love story,
it's a tragedy.
♪ I know my place
I know my place ♪
Lizzy: Well, we have us.
♪
(girls cheering)
And what if this is
our love story?
♪ All the time ♪
♪ I'm grateful all the time ♪
Goodness, what a lady you are.
Mm. All I've ever wanted to be.
♪ I'm pretty when I cry ♪